[Music]
in America's election headquarters this
is primary day in eight states Democrats
are hoping to wrestle at least 23 House
seats from Republicans to take control
of that chamber most of the day
attention tonight is on California where
that state's unusual primary format has
opened all kinds of possibilities for
the November ballot correspondent Peter
Doocy is in San Diego tonight on jungle
primary day Republicans have been
leapfrogged
they are certainly the third most
popular group for the first time in
California where the top two primary
candidates advance regardless of party
there are now more voters registered as
having no party preference than there
are registered GOP Democrats remain in
first place so that means to win
Republican candidates must get creative
candidates don't have to be doctrinaire
tick the box Republicans it gives them
some flexibility on issues that the
electorate may be more moderate than say
you know red state strategy and the
southern strategy would dictate one
Republican candidate for Congress thinks
better GOP registrations will come with
better GOP campaigns you start winning
elections nobody wants to be with the
party but loses the Democrats win the
most statewide but their stats are
stagnant the Democrats have to be
cautious here too because their numbers
haven't grown over that twenty years
instead what's happened is they'd be and
the people would declined to state a
political party have grown
despite the Democratic lead it still
costs them millions of dollars to
compete in the gubernatorial primary
progressive Democrat Gavin Newsom has
spent almost 15 million dollars about
three times more than Republican John
Cox I have seen this movie before where
frontrunners take things for granted and
they just read the polls and then folks
it allegedly were supportive don't
turnout because they think oh that
person's got it and those folks are
looking for work same story in Southern
California House races where the
Democratic Congressional Campaign
Committee has pumped more than two
million dollars into retiring Republican
Edie Royce's district one point six
million dollars on retiring Republican
Darryl ices district and one point eight
million dollars on Dana Rohrabacher
district where Democrats might not even
high enough to make it to the midterm
that's where Democrat Harley ruda is
appealing to this ballooning number in
the middle to avoid being left off the
November ballot I think most Americans
are between the 20-yard lines in there
they're tired of the partisan politics
so each party has a math problem
Republicans don't have as many
registered members as they would like
but Democrats have too many
congressional candidates splitting up
the votes in some districts that makes
it uncertain that Democratic candidates
will advance past tonight in every
single district and that could spoil
their sides chances of using new seats
in Southern California to retake the
house Brett Peter Doocy live in San
Diego Peter thank you we'll have those
results late tonight eastern coast East
Coast time